foreign
that's not his last name by the way
um today we want to talk about a very
sensitive topic so a little disclaimer
if you're a brother and it's for you if
your sister you might want to tune out
or maybe not even watch it at all maybe
just send the video to like your brother
or your your Wally or something like
that
so we're gonna be talking today with the
disclaimer said
but we would like to you know definitely
smash the like button we got share
called Nika back in the building
with this disclaimer being said we will
get into the topic and the topic is
this size matter
excuse me size for what bro
we gotta be specific man we can't have
false you want me to say like specific
words
algorithm academic yes exercise of what
bro okay you're the the male
reproductive organis yes Venice so
Gabriel does size matter bro
you go you're gonna talk about it
we're not gonna talk about a male
anatomy
no problems they know exactly what the
inductive organ is bro
they put me on the spot like that right
well first and foremost why is it
important to have this discussion like
why would we even get onto this right
people might be like man these guys are
crazy which way are they going and so on
and so forth so why is this topic
important it's important because we live
in a time where
society's hypersexualized
and based on our work as counselors we
find that a lot more couples are having
problems when it comes to intimacy
people don't know why
people have problems but people don't
understand why they have problems
when you don't understand why you have
problems you don't know how to solved
them
so that's something very important so
intimacy is
probably one of the most important
aspects of marriage Allah
that he has created spouses for us and
he has put between his love and mercy
now the first thing Allah uses love
obviously today
21st century people are mostly used to
like sex
or you know the f word and whatnot
people talk like that um and okay
the label or the the word whatever but
the the
action itself has become
almost just very animalistic it's
lacking emotion lacks passion yeah it's
just very Primal um
okay I'm not saying that that's not part
of it it is part of it
but it seems like it's the only thing
now and that's been popularized with
social media
videos videos
pornography is huge it's played a very
very big role and for people who know
the or probably don't know the history
of porn
but um
at the time when porn was released we
didn't know a lot about or we didn't
know as much as we know today about the
human brain and how the human brain
reacts to
to pornography or to just seeing things
right any bit of information can
actually
alter the way your brain works a lot of
people understand that the smallest bit
of information smallest amount of
information
why do you think tick tock
has such a strong algorithm but has a
specific
system where you swipe very short videos
the concept of everything being fast
drive through
you know everything's on Instagram
right it's not done haphazardly like
people have actually studied it
I would refer people to a documentary
called the corporation
um to understand a little bit more about
the psychology behind advertisement and
and how how it works how the media works
it's a great documentary you can find I
think online right now but I remember we
studied this in in Family Psychology
class
and
this the psychologists caught up
on how to use the science
of of the brain of how humans react to
information
for the benefit of organizations
corporations and so on people sell stuff
in the end that's what it's driven to
it's everything is about making money so
poor
point is about making money it's one of
the greatest Industries in the world
it's probably combines Hollywood and
volume together
okay people spend a lot of money
watching porn but what they don't
understand is the the outcomes of
pornography is not just companies making
money
is people destroying their brains
literally it's like you're destroying
yourself destroying your family
destroying your life how does it affect
your brain well
basically
the brain as it develops let's say
most young men
and women women watch porn as well they
lie that they don't but today with the
cookies
they're not a chocolate chip cookies
they're real cookies that track your
internet activity so now porn sites they
release the information and statistics
and so on again for the purpose of
making money
also they want to see what people look
at what are the trends what's trending
to basically produce more of that
content because that what people watch
that's what they want and that's what
makes money so we have about 10 years of
stats now that you can compare and see
trends
when it comes to porn and porn sites and
women are definitely there
women watch porn more than men what I
mean more is more time time wise length
men usually watch about five minutes
and we know why and women need a bit
more time so they watch about 13 to 15
minutes on average
right when it comes they're not reading
romance novels anymore
um the romance novels you know the Fifty
Shades of Gray and all the uh that's
something the incense the candles the
bath none of that yeah that's still
there but I think
it's easier now and part of it is having
access like women have more access now
to the mobile phone before it would take
a lot of courage to walk into a store
and buy a magazine as a woman I mean
guys would do it they don't care right
but for women to have to go buy condoms
or anything right right so it's much
more easier but um
so these these sites these these people
have caught up on it so the way are you
gonna just answer your question so your
children around the age of 11.
both girls and boys that's kind of the
average age that they get for their
first exposure
either through uh you know friends
showing them at school schools are huge
when it comes to influencing people
literally like both brothers and sisters
have reported that it's it's something
like yo watch this yeah let me show you
something anyone goes in like the class
and then they kind of look at it and
what you don't understand that initial
exposures well I've had so many clients
who said I can't forget that
and it has kind of paved
specific genre of porn
you know so I know a lot of people
you know they'll find this a bit um
touchy touchy but yeah
like our team counsels both men and
women so we have a specific program
called maitasia and that has two Wings
men and women as well so for porn
addicts right
and
we get a lot of info so a lot of the the
sisters for example or brothers who come
to these programs they're already past
that okay I mean I want to talk about
this like I'm I need help I need to open
up and people say why would the people
tell their sins you should be telling
your sins there's a difference between
telling your sins to people exposing we
have
um confidentiality we don't know these
people are we don't know them personally
it's not like
you're not boasting about it but they're
they've reached a level where like my
life is messed up and bro usually at
that level too it violates your moral
compass too because we were talking a
couple episodes ago that eventually you
don't watch vanilla stuff anymore
there's like child stuff there's animals
there's weird operas right now and that
is because
so you expose that that young age in
those formative stages your brain and
your sexuality is very malleable
it's very fluid here a lot of people
don't understand sexuality they think
that okay you're born on the fitra no
doubt you're born in a fit men like
women women like men and that's it
that's how you want butt sexuality is
um can be changed like and I'll give you
a Nick from a [ __ ] out perspective why
see Allah wouldn't make something Haram
if it's not possible
right like Allah didn't okay uh make for
example I don't know
sticking toothpaste back into the tube
or something you know it's like it's
hard to do it you know but Allah has
made for example
um homosexuality lesbianism bestiality
pedophile all these Haram right it's a
huge punishment in Islam the very strict
people don't understand you're saying
basically like things that are
impossible would not be it would not be
right because it's not even it's
impossible so for example like saying
you being born this way and then being
punished for being gay would not be
Haram because you can't be born that way
you're not born so that makes sense you
can be prone to swinging that way and
don't talk about why everyone men and
women yeah this is clear it's been
studied it's been proven there's a
genetic yes it's it's an issue of
perversion that's why it's punished like
the processant for example he wouldn't
allow the sahaba
to look at young men with no beard
okay they would have to lower the case
there's a young boy who have feminine
traits it was Haram to look at them
right this is very clear in the Sunnah
you'll be like oh what the gay or
something like that stuff no it's like
because there's a feminine trait maybe
that might attract uh someone same with
women right they're not supposed to
expose their Aura in front of each other
you know this whole like girls being
very touchy feeling it's not allowed in
Islam a lot of girls don't know we're
girls we can't do that it's okay you
know because everyone's you know expects
it or it's okay with it it's not allowed
yeah it's not allowed okay people
understand that why is it not allowed
because it can happen right why do for
example this oh the process I'm saying
Hadith that children you should separate
them bad at a certain age and you know
not share the same blanket
why you know because there's things that
are possible to happen have that happen
and we've all known ever heard about it
we know not just heard about it we deal
with these things
because so when has the process
is
if you have no
shyness or no you're not ashamed you'll
do anything that you please
I mean it's crazy bro like
you know we have
some shocking cases I don't think even
though most ready for this stuff you
know like I don't I don't think when we
sometimes I release some small stories
on my
Channel and people are like oh man I
don't think this exists I'm like you
have no clue it's like 30 of what we
actually deal with literally bro wow so
the child is exposed to that
and they grow 12 13 14 15 their body
changes a lot those pathways are
strength and more and more their
condition
um there's neurotransmitters that are at
work and the specifically there's one
called dopamine right and the threshold
of dopamine changes right and that's
where it's kind of linked to
you know the shock effect and change in
sexuality for example all right so uh
you watch okay this and then doesn't
work anymore because your threshold has
increased you need more dopamine now you
need something more shocking so you go
to like I don't know something weirder
and weirder and both men and women
weirder a bit it's a bit more dangerous
with women
because with guys there's a limit to
what they can take
and in terms of imagination and fantasy
it's not that much yeah that as well as
physiologically speaking so we'll suffer
from like guys will stop usually due to
premature ejaculation or erectile
dysfunction they're kind of like oh my
God I'm messed up like it's not working
anymore what do you need everything
works it's gonna if it doesn't need to
work it's just the slippery slope is
there you know it's so it's more
dangerous with women that's why women
don't really come and seek help not so
many and they're not really so I would
say it's more dangerous but guys are
kind of like oh my God I'm messed up I'm
gonna get married and it's not working I
need help
so yeah you're changing your brain is
changing and
you end up getting married or close to
getting married you're an adult now
and
the question is the size matter do these
things matter
and for a lot of people to answer
biologically
no
psychologically yes
what do you mean by the
so when I researched this and
for example
from an anatomical point of view
unless a person is really
suffering
and is below really below the world
average what is it what is World average
whatever is 5.6 inches 5.6 yeah this is
the world average yeah erect yeah okay
yeah zoom in on that bro
yeah people like eggplant there we have
some higher yeah okay so 5.6 inches is
the average erect length yeah still
brothers are watching this nonsense yeah
I don't want to inspire some thoughts no
not not flaccid yeah okay so 5.6 and
um most women what they report they're
okay with five four point five five it's
okay it's fine some women like they
can't even
physiologically is
if you look at it
there's nothing beyond that kind of that
connection
there's a difference opinion about that
but anyway it's it's a lot of women say
it's just enough from biological
perspective even when you look at the
anatomy of the woman
most of her pleasure spots are outside
not inside they're not internal right of
course you have the uh the G-Spot and
whatnot but that's most women report
they cannot so then what does it mean to
be
perceive this psychologically like big
rummies like I could see it and he's
stinking is his mind's working right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
well look so again so biologically
no even there was an interview a lot of
like porn stars were interviewed
and
the women were saying no it's not it's
not like I mean sometimes too big it
just doesn't work like there's no
intimacy you cannot have a proper
position
but would be like psychologically it
would you it would have been like you
taking the right angle of like picture
for your your wife like before you know
like you're getting you get in the car
and you're like hold up I gotta go to
the bathroom
and then I don't know what we're talking
about I'm so lost
um
I think I think what what we should
start with definitely is this question
that we get from sisters more than men
but we also get it from both
um
salaam alaikum t3m we're talk I'm
talking to this brother and I'm
considering getting married but you know
he told me this is how big he is
rather she should have said this is how
small yes and is this going to lead to
problems and they they ask like what is
you know can I can I do something with
that should I marry him because and
these are virgin women bro virgin sister
is wondering is two inches he said he's
2.6 I was like bro how does a man even
know he's 2.6 bro like what type of
number is that bro
at least every guy's measure at least 20
times in their life right and there's a
lot of OCD that's related to that okay
and it causes a lot of social issues
anxiety and man a lot of problems like
it's an actual condition you can search
a lot of men have super printouts and a
lot of the guys who have doubts are okay
now the ones obviously like two point
something then there's a condition
called micropenis what is that and it's
basically micro no like what is the size
for a micro penis yeah like something
like that 2.6 you know okay very very
big you better break some hearts right
now bro very below I don't think many
guys have this is very rare condition
but that requires medical intervention
and so on and what like what type of
surgery yeah surgery the problem is with
C with like women right they want
there's something's not the size that
Society uh asks for this is so unfair
isn't it uh the girls can go and get
breast implants body implants everything
on your lip jobs everything man right
you know what I'm saying but for the men
it's like what do you get because it's
very it's very unsafe that
part of the body that Anatomy is is very
complicated so like the whole thing
might not work you know 10 inch Longs
you see on on the videos that's not
that's not realistic then uh well look
uh we'll get into that but
so yeah these questions do come Brothers
will send these questions sisters will
sense why do they send these questions
is because porn because of society
because of this idea and that brother so
many misconceptions for example like the
specific cultures are this you know
they're like whatever this is a
misconception you look at there's now
studies to show you can look at averages
across the world you can look at talk
about African-American it's not just
about that that's like that's like one
of the
because like for example the biggest
size was reported by an Italian
you know in the world you know what I
mean and there's like I think it's like
uh not Colombians but
somewhere in South America those are
actually by average the biggest right so
it's not African let's say smallest no
yeah you like that one too bro not
Colombia how dare you yeah anyway
um
but there's a lot of misconception right
like we just talked about like hand size
and feed size right people are looking
it's not there's no correlation then why
do they say you know you know what they
say about a guy with bigger feet that's
again uh it's they're misconceptions
people have these these preconceived
ideas
you know what I mean and it's not like
that
but
culture pushes these through movies
um
through social media and whatnot so
there's a lot of Doubt on on different
you know women have that what should I
do if this happens
um guys like oh my God am I doomed and
whatnot
just that's how it becomes psychological
yeah just think about it man like you
could go your entire life let's say you
never watch TV let's say like in the
society like they never really talked
about it you can go your entire life
with like well let's say you have five
inches of CCS or whatever right you
wouldn't even know if that's big that's
small you would have no idea you
wouldn't even care especially as a woman
right like a virgin woman for example
now there's a difference between a
virgin non-virgin but a virgin woman if
that's all she experiences bro and
that's it man she's super happy right
but then constantly she watches these
[ __ ] videos people talking about you
know like your [ __ ] the [ __ ] Down's
gonna play with you like oh it's better
you should try it what not
and people just from there they're just
gone and the mind changed right because
you start thinking you start and all of
a sudden what you have is not good
enough
it's kind of like you have a I don't
know some
cheap car and then you see people
flashing their
crazy cars in front of you all the time
start comparing you start feeling man
it's not good enough you start working
towards no I want to have this or I want
to have that maybe you can't have it so
yeah it is psychological and for women
once they've been conditioned to that
right their brain now we have to
understand for a woman the most
important sexual organ
is the brain
right A lot of people think it's no it's
something else it's the brain is this
head guys it's not the other head down
there it's right there so when one of
them has woman has that expectation I
think now there's a
something trending called something big
the powers big the energy energy right
like a lot of people have asked me about
that bro you know this is some
inappropriate why do women talk like
they're Muslim women
you know those say something oh if I've
saved myself uh so much and I protect
myself with hijab uh
you know I deserve this you know I
should have this stuff like that the
guys are like oh man I'm not like that
and then they feel bad and
they don't want to pursue marriage
they're and they have lack of loss of
confidence and one and the woman now
she's expecting that and psychologically
if she gets something less than what
she's expecting she's gonna think she
got the short and Destroy not just that
it's like it's gonna affect her ability
to to climax
um because she's gonna think it's it's
less attractive than what she thinks it
so her expectations are like
hyperinflated now right and then for a
man his insecurities are hyperinflated
exactly because he's comparing himself
to what he thinks he should be
okay and when you watch these videos I
just want to say one thing quickly when
you watch these videos most if not all
of these videos have way above average
sizes
so the man's gonna think everyone has it
right
so about you
in in porn specifically they're going to
pick the guys that are obviously above
average so now guys are watching this
they're like man look at that
and the girls are gonna watch that and
they're like man look at that that's
what I'm expecting
is this intentional
yeah of course of course because the way
again psychologists have caught up on
that uh the brain reacts to things that
are inflated
over
exaggerated okay right we like all right
same with women's sports yeah exactly
right
and they will portray that they will
show that that makes money that gets the
views
so now people are sitting there I think
this is reality while nothing is reality
in this nothing is reality when you're
watching these uh like everything is
hyper sexualization like 50 cameramen in
the room lighting someone who everything
that doesn't happen like all of a sudden
wow it's like this amazing uh you know
session actually most people will never
have this amazing session especially the
first time it takes months or not years
for couples to actually sink when it
comes to love making and it's probably
like
very small percentage where they're just
all of us you know this perfect you know
match from the beginning doesn't work
like that
so that influences you know expectations
people are disappointed people make
mistakes on their first night of
marriage
um there's a difference as we said
between virgins and non-virgins
obviously a non-virtual woman is a bit
different than a virtual
you know for a virgin woman a lot of the
guys might be like having doubts about
their size which he might be like quite
big actually but he's like so insecure
uh you know let's say he's average right
but it's very insecure
and he takes a virgin and he just wants
to smash it on the first night and he
traumatizes her because she can't just
take it like that bro it's bro it's
super hard you know it's super hard the
guy just thinks I'm just gonna perform
on her like what I've seen and I you
know I'm insecure I'm just gonna do a
really you know amazing and he
traumatizes her and she's
like what the heck is this and then she
doesn't want to get close to him she's
probably not going to talk about it
there's going to be issues and start
sleeping separate beds separate rooms
and then Mary just goes out right not
with a non-virgin woman
it's a bit different obviously she's had
experiences or experience it's a bit
more complicated there you have to have
a bit more knowledge a little more a
little more a little bit more so I don't
know like I guess uh it's more
complicated I do want to give you a huge
shout out bro mashallah that we've spent
what 27 minutes thus far still haven't
directly answered the question but
that's that's because you're the king of
retention time but you're gonna make
sure that we Max the analytics both they
watch the entire video just to get the
answer bro everyone's just still at the
edge of their seats yes there's a no God
just wait we're not gonna give it to you
that easy I mean I think you did kind of
answer it it's a physiology not directly
bro not directly
this man is in the 21st century
I guess it matters
right
in the 21st century like dealing with so
in in today's society I think it does
matter
because of the expectations because of
how we've been conditioned because what
we've seen how it affected our brain
and that's one of the questions that
comes to us is okay so
what do we do like are we
like okay someone's gone through this
trauma someone's been exposed to this
where's where are the boundaries of the
Haram right so let's say a woman's been
conditioned to
have specific intimacy or expectations
of a specific interest right she marries
a guy who is very super Pious he has no
clue about anything he just wants to get
in and get out
is that marriage going to work it's not
gonna work in the 21st century it's not
going to work
he can say well well I'm going to
divorce her okay so you're going to
divorce her
and you can have a another divorced
woman
who's got high sex drive you know just
what do you think she's gonna do like do
people actually think that women are
just going to sit around there and just
wait for some night in shining armor to
come and rescue her yeah you're talking
about here like
stream use of pornography uh build those
toys like sisters are engaged in this
kind of behavior vibrators you know any
like I'm again I don't want to
generalize we're talking about here from
cases that we know hmm
this is the reality people are going to
say stuff for Allah this is bad and
we're not talking here about to impress
you we're talking here that we have a
problem how do we fix it right how do we
fix it do you just write someone off
because they've had an experience like
let's say okay I'll give you an example
so this guy marries a sister
is a Sheikh right
so she's like a convert
right
and he's all excited oh yeah convert not
use typical traditional guy he's got
some knowledge of things obviously he
lives in the West
he said I like I know about these things
but
so the sister you know they consummate
the marriage
and this is like a freak you know it's
got like tattoos all over piercing she's
just like he says I I've never
experienced that as I was like you know
so and then
I was happy he says I was happy
I left whatever went to the museum after
the Salah I opened my phone come back I
need more
so he's like oh super it goes back you
know free clicker like an info like she
really want to stop her like you know hi
hi drive you know he's like in two weeks
after divorce I was that I was dead he's
like I just I couldn't take it right I
was like so I was like bro like yeah her
problem is no but see the thing like
what do you say like a shield what
you're gonna like make the fear on her
or something like that you could it's a
reality she's she's trying to protect
herself in halal yeah she's got a high
drive
she didn't she's wearing hijab
everything properly she's not like some
you know it's just when hijab went off
it was like man what's going on how dare
you
so this is just one example by the way
but this is a real case scenario so what
happens the guys he divorced her now
what do you have you have a hijabi
sister who's a freak
who has a past obviously she's trying to
make Toba you can tell her like sister
stuff for La fast okay fine but in the
end that 10 20 years of experience
cannot just be erased she's conditioned
she's hardwired at that point too does
that mean you have to kick her in the
back and into jahannam or something like
that no because she should be looking
for someone who's more compatible to her
like a brother with the higher sex drive
or something right and how do you get to
understand that that's another story
right because that's like should you
just like even these kind of discussions
oh he told me this is his size like how
do you even get to that discussion
you know what I mean like how do
Brothers back some like my sister you
know my name is this and that and I am
this and like should it be on your CV
now like well I'm six foot two
uh 5.8 like you know is it like how do
you even get to that you know like we
don't really have anymore that's the
thing bro sister's asking whatever but
you know you know what to the man but
the sisters asked that as well exactly
yeah so you're dealing with these these
are real problems people could say no we
shouldn't go to this we shouldn't talk
about this
but then
most of the marriage are falling apart
because of this
I can imagine bro like guy walks in sees
his wife doing herself like I get so
many in this case what should I do
what's the problem what's the problem oh
she's about she's a bad woman okay fine
she this Haram but there's more than one
reason why she's doing that
just like there's more than one reason
why sometimes wives walk on
their husbands and cash them do with
them there's more than one reason
you know it's not just that the guy's a
bad person okay it's Haram he's he's not
he shouldn't be doing that shouldn't be
but there's other issues as counselors
as imams people look at it from a from
many different perspectives it's not
just one reason but this is like this is
on the table this is what we're dealing
with today how do you fix it
okay everyone just goes to hell that's
not that's you know it's so simple right
okay they're all going to hell you know
they're bad people
like
okay she's a convert that's all she knew
she's making Toba now she's coming to
Islam she realized that Islam is the
truth okay how do you deal with that
kind of person
[Music]
um
you know what I mean like how do you
heal it bro this is where like we need
to understand that like our spouses are
significant others they have rights over
us right yeah as a man as a woman
doesn't matter but if if I'm a man and I
have a wife like listen like if if I'm
speaking theoretically I don't want to
like
say anything that's like okay this is
how I am because there's no reason for
that right let's say that I have a high
sex drive well she needs to understand
that and she needs to understand that
okay like I'm probably gonna need more
just like if it was the opposite if like
you said if she has a higher sex drive I
need to understand this
exactly I need to be able to
basically uh coexist with that and make
that happen because if not then I'm
gonna be denying her rights and that's
when okay yeah like you said you know
what she would be doing would be Haram
but it's not fully on her because
it takes two wasn't it
who basically said that men like in
battle they have to return in a specific
amount of time like yeah every three
months every three months minimum it's
amazing the story you cannot deny your
wife more than three months uh even
three months I mean it's hard but why
did he make that uh time period is that
I guess he was walking on the street he
would actually have his tour his room
you would talk to women yeah it's not
how he would talk to him
saying something if I don't fear Allah
my bed would be shaking that's what the
Poetry means and then he actually
knocked the door and said look I've
heard it imagine she would have been
like running what she said and he asked
like how how long can a woman last I
remember she said something like three
months he made it then he made it that
men have to return
uh but here you have a few things number
one is that okay there's Haya and
shyness when you talk about these things
but there's a problem so he's fixing a
problem
okay so let's deal with this issue now
as you said how do you know whether
you're compatible can you talk about
this should you put it on your resume or
CV you know you write your profile and
this you know high sex drive man you
know uh you know big daddy [ __ ] whatever
it's not can you should you most people
say it's bad like I don't have the
answer but we need olama to discuss this
in today's context how do we solve this
I don't think we should put it on the CV
I don't think it should just people
should just jump into the discussion
yeah my name is this and this how you
know a guy yeah
I don't think so but so they need to
answer this question like what's
permissible how can we
giving this problem that we're faced
with today where everything is so
inflated and people have been exposed to
so many things can you just say well
people should just fear Allah okay fine
we should I totally agree 100
so let's say a brother who hears Allah
and his sister of fear Allah get married
together
one has a high sex drive for whatever
reason maybe porn may be just natural
okay maybe just naturally they have a
high sex drive hormones whatever it
could be from food could be from
environment whatever it is
culture some cultures are more prone to
you know intimacy and have higher sex
drive because of the even the diet
the climate influences and so on and so
forth so you know let's say the guy's
like oh yeah I'm this culture but I like
this culture so two different cultures
coming together
with good intentions but then they're
not matching on that um
what's what's the outcome usually okay
have patience
yes of course you should but how much
but for how long how long can a person
actually last right
um how do we solve this problem
who will solve this problem
usually men are just resorting to pawn
or you know otherwise yeah
women cheat men cheat women who are
married will go to the
toy shop and get something extra you
know because it's not enough it happens
more like guys be like I caught her
doing that you know imagine like how
it'll break you bro can we not
can we not uh deal with these issues a
little bit ahead of time so we don't
reach that point I don't I don't have
the answer I can't I'm not a an island
in that point to give a fatwa and say
but most people be like no
you know like how do you I don't know
man I don't have the answer to be honest
like we really need to tackle this issue
because it's causing a lot of divorce
people say well the
the uh
solution is just fear Allah I agree man
I agree no doubt but then again you look
at the history of Islam
theories what you should do yet many
people have done otherwise than what you
should do but how do you deal with that
how do you manage that
how do you manage the reality the
situations that actually take place as
opposed to the theory where you should
fear Allah you should do this you
shouldn't do that but most people
fall out of that
so this is the the question that I mean
we need to to understand
so I have a question
and it's kind of like it's bringing you
back for sure but
um you have mentioned everything that
you mentioned especially about like the
psychological aspect
now let's say
let's say that this is actually
occurring now you have a man
he's talking to this woman about to get
married
but like
some reason in her mind she's over here
expecting something big like what's
what's gonna happen if this guy is uh
I don't know if he doesn't meet these
expectations how can he basically
finesse the situation not even finish it
okay that's that's a good one how can he
like bring the frame in his control to
where he's making her like
psychologically okay even perceive him
as big so he doesn't have a dick big
that's that's how you get around YouTube
algorithm bro let's say you say it
without the other way around a dick a
dig big big yeah dig big well that's
what I was asking he doesn't have one I
was joking about that but I'm saying
like in all seriousness okay it's a good
question
um again looking at it from a
psychological perspective as I said
biologically there's a virgin woman
actually
need something like that no
in her mind she thinks she does because
again she's been conditioned to believe
so
um
she might get disappointed at the
beginning but when it actually gets down
to it
uh if the guy is confident enough which
he might not be because he's also been
brainwashed brainwashed right so that's
where the issue starts it's that the
quality of the intimacy is going to
suffer because her expectations are not
met he's already not able to perform
because he's already in his mind
thinking that oh my God she's not going
to be happy and whatnot but the guy
understands it's all about knowledge
like knowing
what's enough what's not enough
understanding that he comes in confident
and does well because he is confident
then everything will be fine because her
biases will be broken
because in the end if he's she's pleased
doesn't matter what size he is she's
going to be pleased and she's like wait
a second it doesn't really matter and
that's why a lot of women after that
they'll seem like no no I don't I'm okay
with just the average it's more than
enough yeah now this is this is good
because it kind of leads into a question
that I had because I from what I'm
hearing every time we talk about this it
seems to be the case here you're talking
about actual like full-on intercourse
right like the guys Oregon the woman's
organ but aren't there other ways to
please yourself like I'm thinking you're
talking about the size and everything
what if a man goes down in his wife what
if a man you know warms you up with his
hands and things like that or let's say
like a man walked down his wife doing
whatever uh I mean you can crack me from
wrong what if the best thing would be to
jump in on it you know and start replace
your hand with yours
personally I don't think that would be
good just because like you're
it's like a bad behavior you'd want to
like yeah you don't want to reinforce it
yeah it's right so I would say that most
men have no clue what they're doing
about female sexuality and most men not
all men most men and it's an issue of
knowledge and understanding but indeed
um
well see most women you don't want to
teach them or to but they already are
they already know that like they're
already conditioned to that they've
themselves experienced that uh so they
have
they're used to a certain way and if the
guy understands the female biology and
which again most men don't
um yes there's other ways
to to to please own like extremely
pleaser then her mind's gonna change so
I'm like wait a second I don't need that
crazy thing or what I saw is not real it
starts changing her mind
and the couple can have great intimacy
if both of them
specifically the men because see the man
why is the
the burden on the men most because he's
the kawam he's the you know man he's The
Giver men gear right women just receive
I was just about to say man give like
everything points to that
so if he understands what he's doing and
he gives it properly then the woman's
gonna be super happy that's what's so
important for the man to have the frame
like a proper proper frame because if
the man is in his masculine but he could
literally just like if he catches his
girl doing that he could literally say
like take that and throw it out she'll
throw it up and then like he he's gonna
please the tour she's not even gonna be
thinking about doing that stuff so this
is why I say like I think it's super
important and many many women who are
fulfilled report that they're like once
they have the right man he knows what
he's doing they can't revert back to
doing it themselves because it's like no
I just doesn't can't she's like it don't
work yeah it's not I'd rather wait yeah
you know two three months than to
actually just get myself going because
it just nothing can replace what he does
you know right yeah but if the man
doesn't have frame but if the man
doesn't have frame if he's like a little
insecure a little thing and then a
woman's gonna smell that she's not
against psychological she won't be able
to reach that level of pleasure because
her brain won't allow it because of the
what he's what kind of frame he brings
to the to the bedroom
right it's Irreplaceable you know she's
gonna feel that man you know like again
the woman like the woman starts from
here you know literally Bros like
you know science shows that a woman it
takes about what an average about seven
to eleven minutes for it to organs
man about two minutes bro on average you
know what I mean that's crazy look at
the difference right so it means like
what do you do in those seven minutes
the difference right so uh but if the
man knows what he's doing and can
penetrate here first like guys are
jumping I gotta do this I gotta do that
this technique and that thing no man
that's an investment no you gotta know
what you got to say not just it starts
way before even reach home bro you can
text a little thing here you start
preparing it prove it like 30 of the
work's already done you know what I mean
but again you need to know and to know
you have to understand something that
most men are not willing to understand
humble themselves to understand a female
are much more sexual than men their
whole body the way they're designed like
I mean they have an organ that it's all
about pleasure there's not no other
function of that organ men don't even
have that we don't know we have other
functions
but specifically like women have that
one thing that's just so women enjoy
more but problem is the whole shaming
they're not able to open up culturally
culturally right it's not shaming
they're scared of that how are you going
to perceive if they enjoy it if they're
going to talk about open about what they
like or they don't like
so then they're they shut down when a
woman psychologically shuts down good
luck opening up again bro and most guys
mess up so the woman's not going to give
a second chance if you get a second
chance you're super lucky bro if you
don't know how to do it properly from
the beginning and I'm not talking about
doing it I'm talking about
getting her to open and to relax and to
just feel sexy and just feel relaxed to
be ready for intimacy that's it bro once
she closes down uh closes up bro it will
be very difficult for her to trust you
to open up she'll do it as a chore but
you might enjoy a little bit but she'll
never reach her full potential
which means you yourself are not going
to enjoy it properly and that's where
the problems start and the man starts
going a different direction she goes a
different direction and that's it if
you're smart enough from the beginning
and you can earn her trust and you're
not going to judge her and say something
stupid you know to make her feel bad
and just let her enjoy know that the
Halal and Haram know the limits
and pure in for a joyride
if not good luck man you're you're
messed up you're done and most guys make
a mistake there
because like they'll start Pro being a
little bit she says something like oh
yeah I like that she's like oh
you know all of a sudden like you'll
just like put it down and there's oh no
I didn't mean it um no never mind you
know
yeah
guys are goofy sometimes oh where'd you
learn how to do that you know yeah what
do you mean it's like bro like how dare
you so so but knowledge is so important
and that's why the beginning of marriage
is so important the night of intimacy is
so important if you are a good you're
not approach it or shall you have a good
intimate life and you mess up that night
it'll be very hard to regain or to speak
or trust and stream by foreplay bro I
think you warmed up all the viewers in
the audience for the next episode
inshallah so there's not much else to
say about this episode we should wrap it
up
um and really you know spend some time
dissecting everything in the next
episode about intimacy
let us know what you guys want to hear
so that size matter yes and no yes and
no yeah there you go yeah but no yes but
no yes yes psychologically yes I think
the major take home just to like recap
everything
is uh number one
have the frame frame probably right
number two confidence foreplay foreplay
before the four play more play before
the four play before the four before
like you got to stimulate the Mind
before you even get to that point and
then the last one to tie it all together
you gotta let your girl be a freak
you got to bring out hello you just have
to let her be a woman bro that's it well
that's that's the thing it's being a
woman let her be a woman in today's not
not totally free not tell her to do XYZ
just let her do her thing you know
that's what I'm saying everyone but just
let her
enjoy herself and she knows other people
enjoy herself the best when she feels
confident if you put her down if you
somehow shame her make her feel she's
ugly like bro just tell your wife she's
the most beautiful thing just say that
over and over tell us she's the sexiest
thing she drives you insane this and
that and you see what happens she will
do that because she will feel like that
and women there's something called
mirror neurons
and women have this very it's very
highly developed in a female man as well
but FEMA more like women love to feel
attractive oh they look in the mirror
and if they feel attractive
if she don't like what she sees
good luck if she likes what she sees and
you have a huge role to play because she
probably don't like what she sees
because she's been conditioned she looks
at Tick Tock Instagram she's all these
fake models you wipe their face with a
baby wipe and it's gone you know what I
mean it's totally different you know
good from far but far from good but it's
it's a deception how dare you I dare
it's deceptive bro women deceive life
with the filter their whole lives are
with filters but your wife looks at this
and she feels like she's ugly
and you might you know she might ask you
things or she might catch you looking at
stuff and like oh that's what you like
and I'm not that she's gonna destroy
herself her her confidence
and forget it she's not going to be
properly intimate with you but if you
know how to change that I'm convince her
that she's beautiful and she is
beautiful man because beauty is in the
eye the beholder who says that she has
to look like that's all fake bro it's
all silicone it's all surgeries not if
you really think about it like we are
done too as men because we start
thinking that's hot it's not hot bro
it's not it doesn't feel hot it just
looks hot but when you really get to the
nitty-gritty of it it's been changed and
some guy put his things in there and
whatnot it's not
but so when you tell your wife no you're
the most beautifully drive me crazy this
and she starts believing it slowly
starts feeling comfortable she sees no I
am beautiful like there's nothing wrong
with that and then you know she when she
looks in the mirror she feels good about
herself then what happens at night is
good man
I think that's very important but I also
think like this is why I kind of like
differ a little bit or like me calling
or letting the girl be a freak I think
this is psychological no doubt because
like women have fantasies a lot more
than men yeah they won't admit it though
and if you can tap into that and you
make her feel like she's fulfilling a
fantasy or she's like being bad like it
stimulates her even more mentally are
you are men ready though to deal with
that because if you get into the the
female's mind her fantasies it can you
know it can be shocked bro it can be
crazy it can be crazy if you're not
ready for that then you're going the way
you're gonna react is gonna shut her off
and once that door is closed you're not
gonna enter it back there bro yes it's
restrain director area and that's it I
mean you get some but it's not going to
be the best yeah
but that's that's the uh that is the
recap that is essentially everything
brought together so again this size
matter uh we'll let you be the judge
after watching this video yeah
it was good enough but um we we make do
all that why do you keep holding like
that bro I like it you like it
take this thing off here so people can
hear me a lot better
yeah so with that being said we hope
that this video has helped you in one
way shape or form
about me with that being said
[Music]
foreign
[Music]